çok güzel bir salon çok genç bir salon e
hocamı dinledik ki ben heyecanlandım o
havalarda uçuyor Ben mikroskobun altında
hücrelere bakıyorum Eee Merhaba
arkadaşlar ben Cihan taştan E bugün size
Ben de kendi hikayemi anlatacağım 2000
yılında Ben hatta olsa galiba Hakkari
yükseko daydım E daha ortaokulun son
seneleri bir haber açıklandı
isimlerini bile unuttum bu muydu galiba
bir haber
açıklandı ve bütün dünya bütün gazeteler
haftalarca bu haberi konuştu 2003
yılında İnsan Genom Projesi
açıklanmıştı yani Bizi biz yapan 3
milyar tane DNA harfinin tümünün
açıklandığı insanı insan y gen
şifresinin çözüldüğü söyleniyordu sizin
yerinizde eydim Hatta sizden biraz daha
küçüktüm ve ben üzülmüştü hayal
kırıklığına uğramıştım dedim ki benim
yapacak başka bir şeyim kalmadı
insanların şifresini açıkladılar
hastalıkları çözecekler Ben ne yapacağım
diye
üzülmüştüm Bundan yıllar yıllar sonra
Anladık ki aslında İnsan Genom Projesi
yani 3 milyar harfin hepsi açıklanmamış
Arkadaşlar bu harfleri yani vücudumuzda
bulunan 46 tane kaset dediğimiz
kromozomlar içerisinde sadece % 1992
yani 3 milyar harfin yaklaşık 2 milyar
800 civarındaki harfin açıklandığı
görülmüştü geri kalan % 8'lik yani 100
sayfadan oluşan Genom kitabımızın
Aslında karanlık kalan 8 sayfasının
yaklaşık 22 yıl boyunca teknolojinin
gelişmesiyle bilimin ilerlemesiyle
açıklanması ancak 2022 yılını buldu ve
2022 yılında biz artık karanlık sayfalar
olan 8 tane daha sayfayı anlamaya
başlamıştık yıl 2022 biz geçen bu kadar
yıl içerisinde Ben moleküler biyoloji
genetik okudum hayatımın son 15 yıı
sentetik biyoloji Mühendislik de geçti
Türkiye'deki ilk genetik tedavileri
insanlara uyguladık Yani biz artık 3
milyar harfi oluşturan 100 sayfayı
sadece Okumakla kalmıyordu artık
okuduğumuz sayfaların yerini
değiştirebiliyoruz sayfalar içerisindeki
kelimeleri harfleri değiştirebiliyoruz
yeni anlamlar
artık geçtiğimiz 20 yıl içerisinde
çözmeye başlamıştık İşte bu sunumun
konusu Aslında İnsan Genom Projesi değil
transhümanizm Yani önümüzdeki yıllarda
artık bambaşka bir evrenin açıldığını
göreceksiniz bu Evren Aslında bizim
yaşam 2.0 dediğimiz sanki bilgisayarlara
bir güncelleme geldiği gibi canlılara da
yavaş yavaş bir güncellem geldiği bir
devre giriyoruz
arkadaşlar 2020 yılı Nobel kimya ödülü
açıklanacak Bundan tam 5 yıl önce Nobel
kimya ödülü 2015 yılında Aziz Sancar
hocamıza verilmişti dna'yı tamir eden
mekanizmaları
keşfettiğinde Benim de hayatımın büyük
bir bölümünü değiştiren yeni bir
mühendislik yöntemi geliştirildi bu
yöntem Cris mühendisliği teknolojisiyle
bu teknolojiyle Biz bitkilerde
böceklerde hayvanlarda ve
özellikle Yüzyıllardır insanların
hayatını kaybettiği tedavi edilmesi
sanılan tedavi edilmesi imkansız sanılan
hastalıkların ki bunlar kanser veya
Nadir hastalıklar dediğimiz
hastalıkların artık % 0'ın Tedavi
edilebileceği umudunu doğuruyordu Biz
gözle görülmeyen o 3 milyar harfin
istediğimiz harfini değiştirebilecek bir
imkana kavuştuk Jennifer DNA ve Emmanuel
charpentier crisper üzerine
geliştirdikleri sistemle Gözde
görülmeyen canlıların Genom kitaplarında
istediğiniz düzenlemeleri yapabilmenizi
sağladı bu düzenlemeler geçtiğimiz 10
yıl içerisinde yüzlerce canlıda gen
mühendisliğinin yapılabilmesini binlerce
Makale yayınlanmasını ve yine aynı
şekilde binlerce patentin alınmasını
sağladı bunlar artık vücudumuza girmeye
başladı özellikle pandemi zamanından
sonraki biyoteknolojik gelişme bizim gen
mühendisliği genetik tedaviler
noktasında da bir Atılım yapmamızı
sağladı burada genetik mühendisliğinin
genetik Tedavinin nasıl İnsanların
hayatına dokunduğunu görüyorsunuz ilk
defa 2019 yılında insanlara
Eee gen hastalığını tedavi edecek
mühendis yöntemi yapıldı Diğer taraftan
bir görme bozukluğu Leb konjenital
amoroz dediğimiz direkt gözün içerisine
gen mühendisliği yapan o Nano robotlara
enjekte edildi Hatta şu an köşede
görüyorsunuz sadece crisper sistemi
değil bizim 10 yıldan uzun uzun bir
süredir çalıştığımız diğer ger
mühendisliği teknikleri de hastalara
uygulanmaya başladı Aslında bu hastalar
bu tedavileri almadığında bütün yaşam
kalitelerini sağlık kalitelerini
kaybedebiliyor ve yeri geldiğinde
hayatlarını kaybedebiliyor Bundan dolayı
son yıllarda gelişen bu teknolojiler
Aslında
etrafımızda tedavi edilen genetiği bir
bakıma modifiye edilmiş değiştirilmiş
tamir edilmiş bir insanlar topluluğunun
da oluşmasını
sağladı bir diğer yöntem Zeno
transplantasyon Ben New York
Üniversitesi'nde doktor aldığımda langon
Medical Center isimli bir hastanede
çalışıyordum 2017 yılında doktorayı
aldım ve Türkiye'ye döndüm İşte o
hastanede Geçtiğimiz aylarda dünyanın
ilk hayvandan insana olan
transplantasyonu yani organ nakli
gerçekleştirildi bildiğiniz gibi organ
nakli Aslında dünyanın en çok büyük
sorunlarından biri birçok insan her yıl
hayatını kaybediyor sadece yeterli bir
organla nakli yapılamadığından ötürü
Neden Çünkü insandan insana bir organın
aktarılması bile bazen mümkün olmuyor
doku uyuşmazlığı veya dokunun birbirini
Redd etmesinden dolayı hemen insanlar
hayatını kaybedebiliyor işte burada bir
domuzdan organ insana nakledildi yani
başka bir canlıdan başka bir canlıya Bu
nasıl oldu yine crisper y mühendisliği
yöntemiyle domuzdaki
yaklaşık 20 tane gen 20 tane bölgenin
genetiği
değiştirildi ve domuzun organı artık
insanın vücudu bizim bağışıklık
sistemimiz tarafından reddedilemez bir
hale geldi ve daha sonra langon
hastanesinde bu nakil gerçekleştirdi
maalesef bir ay kadar önce hasta vefat
etti vefat etmesinin sebebi organ nakli
yapıldıktan sonra domuzdan bulaşan bir
bir domuz virüsünden dolayı öldü ama bu
yine Bu başarının önüne
bu dediğim teknolojiler sadece
hastalıkların tedavisi değil Özellikle
yaklaşık 10 milyon insanın vefat ettiği
hayatını kaybettiği covid-19 pandemisi
Ben yıllarca E bu aşı üzerinde çalıştım
geri geldi bu
virüsleri litrelerce ürettik Ama artık
böyle tehlikeli virüsleri üretmek yerine
gen mühendisliği yardımıyla
Biz antimikrobiyal aşılar üretmeye
başlayacağız artık ık bu Genetik
mühendislik teknolojilerini bir HP
olarak yutağı bakteriler virüsler Yani
bizi öldürmeye yakın olan bütün
mikropları daha vücudumuza girmeden
öldürebilecek hale geleceğiz İşte bu
teknolojiler sadece kanser Nadir
hastalıklar organ yetmezliği gibi değil
aslında dışarıda bizim vücudumuzu hasta
etmeye çalışan bütün organizmaların da
önüne geçebilecek bir
teknoloji bu teknoloji yeni değil
yaklaşık 1990 2000'li yıllarda gen
tedavileri başladı Şu an Dünyanın her
tarafında genetik tedavi çalışmaları
devam ediyor Biz de Türkiye'de Tıp
tarihinde ilk defa birçok hastada
kanserli hastada insanların Kan
hücrelerinde Genetik mühendislik yaptık
ve kanseri tedavi etmek noktasında çok
iyi başarılar
gösterdik burada Tabii o kadar toz pembe
her şey çok güzel gibi ifade etsek de
işte bu trans hümanizmin veya yaşam
2.0'ın Aslında Tedirgin edici yönleri de
var 2017 yılıydı
yine insanlık dondu ve kaldı özellikle
bilim Dünyası bir anda ayağa kalktı
Çinli bir bilim insanı Doktor He
dünyanın ilk genetiği değiştirmiş
bebeklerinin dünyaya geldiğini duyuyordu
burada bizim AİDS sebep olduğunu
bildiğimiz HIV virüsüne karşı bebeklerin
genetiğini değiştirdiğini ve artık bu A
hastalığına yakalanamayan söylüyordu
Tabii bir anda dünya ayağa kalktı çünkü
şu ana kadar hiçbir bebeğin ya da hiçbir
insanın genetiği tamamıyla
değiştirilmemiş Bu bilim insanı hapse
atıldı yüz binlerce dolar E tazminata
tabi tutuldu ve Geçtiğimiz aylarda
hapisten çıkartıldı
Ama artık pandoranın kutusu açıldı
arkadaşlar birçok laboratuvarda birçok
çalışmalarda artık insanlarda embriyo
düzeyinde genetik tedavilerin de
yapılabileceği gibi bir durum çıktı
tabii ki bu yasak çok düşünülmeli çok
iyi denetlenmeli ama biz Artık
önümüzdeki 10 yıllar içerisinde genetik
mühendisliğin gelebileceği uç noktaları
da görmemiz açısından bu örneği vermek
istedim ne kadar hapse atılsa da her ne
kadar hapisten çıkılsa da sonrasında
gelişen olaylar Aslında birçok devletin
perde arkasında bunları düşündüğünü de
söylüyor yine
Çin'de Bununla ilgili çalışmalar
olduğuyla ilgili haberler geliyor
genetiği değiştirmiş askerler süper
askerler Bunlar da önümüzdeki yıllarda
Belki de bizim hiç haberdar
olmayacağımız bir şekilde ortaya
çıkabilecek insan olarak görülebilir
Yani biz Biz bir apokalips çağının
içerisine giriyoruz arkadaşlar dediğim
gibi pandoranın kutusu açıldı Öyleyse
biz bu genetik mühendislikleri bu
yöntemleri en iyi şekilde öğrenmeli
kendi insanlarımızı koruyabilecek en iyi
teknikleri en iyi denetçileri en iyi
yöntemleri kendimizin öğrenmesi
gerekiyor Belki de önümüzdeki yıllarda
bir hastanede Çocuğunuz dünyaya gelmeden
önce onun bütün genomu Yani bizim 100
sayfadan oluştuğunu söylediğimiz Genom
kitabı sadece birkaç saat içerisinde
hemen okunabilecek ve o kişinin
doğduktan sonra maruz kalabileceği Bütün
hastalıklar bir reçete olarak kişinin
önüne verilebilecek ve gen mühendisliği
yöntemleriyle bu çocuk dünyaya gelmeden
genomu tamir edilerek bu çocuklar
hayatını e kazanabilecek işte Yapay zeka
robot sistemler ve aynı zamanda gen
mühendisliğinin birleştiği bizim bios
singularity yani biyoteknik dediğimiz
bambaşka bir Çağa girdiğimiz de önemli
bir özeti yıl
[Müzik]
e gerçekleştiğini
göreceğiz beni dinlediğiniz için
teşekkür ederim
than